[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN GALPIN: Hello, I'm Dan
Galpin for the Developer Show.
This is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The first beta release of
Flutter is now available.
Flutter is Google's
new mobile UI framework
that helps developers craft
high-quality native interfaces
for both iOS and Android.
Get started today with a post
linked in the description
below.
You can now craft your
own bot integrations
using the Hangouts Chat
developer platform and API.
With feature-rich
intelligent bots,
users can automate tasks,
get critical information,
or do other heavy lifting
with a simple message.
For example code and
a link to the docs,
head on over to the post.
We've been working to ensure
that Android apps don't
use non-SDK
interfaces, since doing
so risks crashes for users
and emergency rollouts
for developers.
In Android N, we restricted the
set of symbols that C and C++
code could use.
Starting in the next
release of Android,
we will further
increase stability
by expanding these
restrictions to cover
the interfaces of the SDK.
Head on over to the post for
some more details in what's
next.
Managed import and export
for Cloud Datastore
is now generally available.
Cloud Datastore is
our highly scalable,
NoSQL managed database service.
This feature replaces the
previous Cloud Datastore admin
backup module, and provides
a more fully managed database
experience.
Links to the docs
are on the post.
The Cloud Billing Catalog API
joins the Google Cloud Billing
API to help you manage
your billing experience.
With it you can predict
bills, estimate costs,
and reconcile rates when
you're using list Google Cloud
Platform pricing.
Links to the docs
are on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Dan Galpin for
the Developer Show.
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Figure it was better
than the shaggy look
I had going for the last
time I did Dev Show.
Hi, I'm [INAUDIBLE]----
or even the little--